[Music]
Myrtle dunnage we agree what you got old
doesn't Danny just back haven't seen her
since she was a kid
well now she turned out how's my mother
Emily doesn't get out much
I don't know why you've come to this
hole who lives at mad Molly's now
[Music]
I need to remember the truth they say
that she killed a boy so where does he
go from here I worked in London blonde
in Paris
I reckon you came home for one of two
things revenge or they good at rude
crash the dance is Saturday night the
dress can't change anything
watch and learn Gertrude watching bad I
can make you the most striking girl in
the row take your clothes off a murderer
and a lesbian
[Music]
stunning you can transform people use it
clearly damage
that day she saw the whole thing she
murdered him she's cursed I didn't do it
it's just a pack of lies
they'll never forgive me for the boy's
death you wasted here it's not my charge
I with water sitting
why didn't you tell me
you know it scared me Tilly dunnage
Tilly dunnage you've enriched my life
I reckon you can make something like
pretty happy you could be married in
this suit snapped up by some eligible
spinster or peg
[Music]